how's the go and rest - parent of hat
welcome back to part two of The Walking
Dead goddamnit I was looking forward to
keep playing with Alma and Tricia it's
not her name I keep forgetting she died
- we didn't see it she died off-camera
show she's not really sure I'm pretty
sure she died
hello
not really last time you met strangers
it wasn't me good things I don't see why
we would say hello
oh now what it looks not too bad I guess
surprise me when you go into Shore in
lots of us after you go in the water
what is this
stairs
so we need to get up there huh oh never
mind
shouldn't we check out the boat though
but I want to check out the baby oh damn
Krista are you there I kind of doubt it
but I guess we should look for her at
least oh god don't scare me what is that
a sign I wonder what it says
oh that is attractive add some kinky
[ __ ]
I saw sign and it opened up my skull
that's so a sign
ah
all right let's see what the warning is
wide life huh
Oh God
we literally have nothing to defend
herself with what would what would you
Brazil in a situation like this like
where would you go I wouldn't want to go
up north just cuz it's safer
which way we are pretty
who's out there
Oh birds everywhere seriously come on
climb don't worry about it well I guess
we got to walk down here huh oh that is
a coyote coyote
right doggie Sam it's okay boy
that's okay ah my own
where are your owners they around I want
to pet an wild dog right away they are I
hope they're nice nobody saw the collars
I don't know what's he doing who who is
she talking to that's the question hey
what would you find boy yeah but where
are you going wait up
okay well I guess we have nothing better
to do anyway oh cool thanks Sam hello
looks pretty run over but you never know
let's look around for some food
it's gotta be hard to find food these
days if it's been so long seriously it's
not like cancer food is just lying
around and [ __ ] exactly nothing left
here even the dog bowl says Sam on it
now there are cans over there let's
check that out
let me guess someone's gonna show up and
gonna be pissed that we're here or
what's a dog detergent
empty
I gotta keep looking boy how does she
know it's a boy hmm
frisbee hey wanna play who want to play
catch uh I guess yes
okay forget back
that's a don't wear a ball boy flying
dis let's keep looking
think anyone's been sleeping in here I
can't tell maybe we'd better not wait
around to find out what about these box
whoa that is creepy hmm nothing edible
are you sure clam are you sure that
looks mighty tasty if you ask me
okay let's
so families to stay here looks like they
were a happy family once
how does stealing food behind somewhere
well they left the dog
you
I'm just say I'm the same Oh God
want to go again you think yeah well
I bet you miss this I sure do
let's go one more time go get it boy I'm
hoping he's like gonna go out ah darn it
was good while it lasted though right
uh-huh yeah you're right shouldn't waste
the energy anyway well that's depressing
okay I'll miss to miss a detail here
somewhere all right the bowel
got a check everywhere
come on come you can do it well here we
go
oh that's disgusting
oh my god thank you
look I can yeah man it's probably
something to open it with just break it
on the rock can talk to dog yeah what
what what is it dog hey boy what's the
matter oh no no oh well we have to be
quiet
Oh Shh
ah he's dead no he's not
look you can see the bite who looks like
he tried to cut it out
ah come on never works
well cutting up the arm ders it's okay
we're smart and he's not are smarter
than all of them so obviously what we're
gonna do is take this branch and smack
it in his face
stand back okay good night
Oh
na kama good night good night
I use this won't quit would you
finish yeah again hm
that is brain dang see we just have to
stay out of their reach
he's like what then hey Lee that base
timing to me stirred a lot to think that
if they were alive they'd probably want
to help you nothing yeah poor guy
think he had himself tied up or did
someone force him to do this
I don't think so otherwise he'd cut off
the rope right that looks like it hurt
yeah but let's get it open the can with
that though
still pretty sharp okay
so shouldn't that knife beam fixed
anywhere right
you have to disinfect it
I wouldn't eat with a knife that's been
into his Amy that's his arm saying
please don't be bad oh man she's got
eyes what is that what is that maggots
potatoes thank God
what is it Oh
you hungry I guess you're pretty hungry
too oh how do I feed him here you go Oh
Oh what what way was so sweet that damn
what now
give him a break ah that doesn't make
any sense
ah is it hurt huh we're gonna have to
put him down
I don't like when dogs get hurt sorry
all right
ah
and in stitches
all right
poor Clem she's like the toughest girl
ever seriously I really hope nothing bad
more bad happens right now but I have a
feeling it's gonna
if I remember I I don't want to spoil
actually I saw something on the picture
she could have grabbed the food I
thought she was hungry
Oh No well clam it's gonna be okay don't
I guess she's alone for the first time
hmmm she waking up what is happening I
don't like this no what oh no you can't
sleep there Clem it's not safe nice
jacket really give Clemmie break guys
ah come on uh well we have our knife oh
god oh god he's face
what am i what am I supposed to do come
on
oh man watch out
oh my god is down oh no it's old they're
all
I'm out robber let's go come on kid we
got a key
well that was Nick of a time
Hey
I think I think we're safe
I don't know by the rocks look
suspicious hey you alright
I think so I I think so
well I guess they're nice are you doing
out here where the the people you're
with there's no chance you made it this
long on your own I don't want them
thinking we're doing anything but trying
to help you we were at a friend and I
got attacked hmm
these folks mention what they were after
they might have just wanted food and we
were cooking some sort of weasel they
attacked you for a weasel damn that is
elope they didn't mention any names
right they weren't searching for anybody
what's going on here that guy likes it
like a widely well yes sir I'm Luke this
is Pete later
I'm gonna call you widely I'm sorry I'm
Clementine that's nice to meet you
Clementine but for now we're gonna take
you back to our group okay we got a
doctor with us and you look like you
could use some oh sure oh they thought
you were playing C's oh no it's a doubt
it would [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] what are we
gonna do here nice it is oh it was a dog
I didn't see any dog Clementine come on
kid
we just saw you with those lurkers look
at it no no just look at it please
yeah and have you sink your teeth into
Pete's neck no way my neck why my ha ha
ha ha ha ha ha I'm a mosquito bite from
a lurker bite man it's not
intense hmm all right why don't you just
show a watch yourself
hey don't look at me like that you're
the one that's been here okay
see see that ain't no human I said like
she says well could be a dog hard to say
so weird this dog go the one that did
this know what what does that matter
Pete I killed it I I killed it
what really a dog shows up and bites you
and you just kill it what would you have
done
I don't know it attacked me still you
don't you don't kill dogs that's true
that except when I knew it I guess
Clementine yes you telling us the truth
looked me in the eyes when you answer
yes
all right Clementine
that's good enough for me what else was
she gonna say I've got a good [ __ ]
detector Luke you don't always beat it
all right how can you be sure
well I'm sure I ain't willing to leave a
little girl in the woods to die when we
got a doctor with us that can make a
call we can have Carlos take a look at
it first this time a meeting with
colleges not with what have you don't
have to remind me of that boy all right
sorry sir
do it all pat on the back
Clementine are you feeling alright
I'm fine just tired well you better be
fine cuz I ain't carrying you anymore
with that bite on your arm
don't worry about mm-hmm pork lamb I
would be worried that she turn into
Sammy if that happened but Isis mopping
and buy a thing huh I'm gonna have to
end this episode here but I hope you
enjoyed watching leave a like if you did
I really appreciate it loving this so
far I hope you do as well
it's ask ina comb room with three and I
see Bruce in the next one